hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space all right rolling
right along is that another room yeah it
is a mistic we got in here wait where
they're supposed to go this way there's
like a secret it's been less than an
hour but they've spread fast and
entirely overrun lost at least half the
medical deck and about a quarter of
engineering this is not what I expected
no this isn't what I expected either I
expected reunite with my girlfriend
get dog out of here and go home
get it on oh yeah good thing I did
coming Karen thank you very much
Oh exploration master right here so oh
okay now back this way
oh yeah dudu anyone wanna hang with me
Oh nope nope don't even try
don't even try
okay back down up I probably need to go
up to four three I'm just guessing I
don't know why the elevator actually has
to go physically all the way up I can't
just be like fear dude I wouldn't know
it's level design could make it that way
hello
is it
goes out
whoa whoa yes home again
ah dude you're right there buddy
don't look so good kind of face was kind
of messed up
oh wait you're just born ugly ha ha ha
force gun that sounds like that I can't
use it I'm stuck with you so the bridge
is [ __ ] I don't use bad forever I'm not
sticking around in case where ever did
it comes back I'm heading for
hydroponics to find Elizabeth he's
probably dead but not my girlfriend
she's pried off
totally totally right so Leah I can use
enter an arrow I don't know why I didn't
use that before but I know that now hey
there Oh
yeah you're goofy dead
why were you goofing yeah hi you gave me
a semiconductor left cheap um okay I
pushed another button I completed
another objective
we've got enough power 80s cannons auto
targeting is down I think it's a faulty
data cable okay I need you to aim the
cannon manually until I can replace it
you can be elevated to the top of the
ship and head for the cabin pity okay
oh good thing I came up or went down
first does that I did
John nope but it looks like a room - I
don't trust especially when there's
blood all over the place
now that wasn't a computer announcement
I just heard whispering you may not have
been able to hear that but I heard
whispering yeah that was whispered I was
like a woman who is springing a man
whispered
yeah Isaac's probably going crazy this
is like given now
I wish doors are gonna open oh no it's
gonna trick me who's out there these are
rather dastardly looking walls
hiya box you're going to have to cross
the ship exterior to reach the ATF Canon
core problem is we're still getting
bombarded by asteroids look for cover or
you get torn to pieces okay
Wow I've got a lot of health kits I
should have stopped by the store before
this because there's no way oh man
that's a lot of crap oh I don't need an
AirCam hmm maybe I do not the Wow no
I've got a bad feeling about this I have
a feeling that I'm gonna need that it
can huh oh they say go across the
surface I don't trust going outside if
they're gonna give me an air camera I'm
just calling it I'm gonna oh hell yeah
it looks like I'm gonna need it
get out of my way warning multiple
impacts detected across the stalkers hi
what done what what what the hell I know
my legs okay don't walk there when that
happens uh multiple impacts did maybe
it's like asteroid I don't know I still
have the thingy yep okay let's do this
and not die
drinks - okay maybe I hide behind these
things
Oh oxygen research thank you I didn't
leave the ice detected across the
stallers home
oh I don't look good oh okay I jumped
from cover to cover table I make it here
can I make it to the next ah nope
okay I probably could have made it to
the next one yeah I can probably make it
to two I think maybe
all right hand and and here we go we oh
look at me I'm so fast
oh so fast ah no no no no Oh gotcha
can't fool me I'm running out of here
nope ah can't be be okay I guess it is
good thing that I got this hair cancer
okay I don't think I can make it that
second can i maybe I can let's try it
ah that's right that's right now ah okay
and then use the air canister cuz I'm so
boss like that how pitiful is your
spacesuit it only last 70 seconds Lata
was okay where am I going
can I make it at the end um
I'll wait one more just in case now I
could have made that I'm such a pansy I
don't know why these are just protecting
me from wherever the asteroids are
coming from straight in front of you
whatever I made it
it's I yes I
okay oh this is Ruby semiconductor what
does that sell for tell me nope dental
pride for more huh
probably for you definitely food you're
our deal
oxygen area you mean space uh Daniel
override okay do I get to shoot Oh get
to shoot a big gun
Oh during the fall and they don't even
give me the crappy house cholesterol
your new anything flying at it
oh that I'm nothing get by and we're
dead I think I'm overhead
and it's been doing this for like
whatever
I wish you run barrel
Oh get out here
ah there's too many
not on overheat it's nobody
come on okay I'm super adult I don't
know how my mom at we're gonna die kind
of old guy because I'm bad at this
ah don't overheat okay no double barrel
okay just precision
to present
I did you trust me to this
ah come on
ah come on man up roll
falen here ah
kind of 68 ah the big one ah
hammer here
oh we're on fire all the glass is
cracking ah 50 percent oh that was that
just my armor oh no we're phone logs is
bad it is ah
Oh be a better shot me oh there we go
okay look huh well the targeting is now
on lining Nahum papacy for oh excuse me
queer I'll engage autopilot again that's
the tram station long queue then when
I'm done okay all right got that whoo
I brought [ __ ] safe before that I'll
save town man yeah enter it much faster
okay Wow okay I gotta cut it here but
thank you guys so much for watching
now we'll see you in the next part bye
bye